so let's see if we can remember this
okay sign if you remember it's the
mixed-up one
yeah it's mixed up so it's got signs and
causes lumped together so how does it
start
sign a plus B we try and get the angles
right so we're gonna have our A's first
and then our B's first okay so sign a
what sign a what follows Busby thank you
plus and then they switch around right
so if we take the angles in the same
order
you'll get close x9 beer okay now before
we leave off this okay this is what we
call a some expansion as in you know
when you add things up okay
because assign a plus B right you can
see from here if you think back to our
work on automated functions right it's
very easy once you know this expansion
to work out the difference expansion so
instead of a prospect what if we had
sign a minus B if that was the only
difference okay so what I'm going to do
is consider this as just a version of
the previous life okay so it's a
difference but I'm gonna consider it
like a song so I'll take sign off a plus
and it's a little bit like to remove
doing addition subtraction of graphs you
know adding and subtracting coordinates
okay so this is plus negative B you see
I haven't really done anything yeah now
if that's the case everywhere I've got
to be here
in my previous dimension I'll put their
negative bit so do we go it pays are the
same sign a instead of Cosby I'll have
cos of negative it okay
and then in the same way along he'll
have sign off negative B instead of side
B okay now again remember ordered even
functions right cos cos positive even
function sort of looks like okay so you
got your reflection across the axis even
functions be f of X is f off
- X good so here this thing here cuz of
negative B that might be over here right
should be exactly the same it's cos B
right there's a reflection there so I've
got sign a cos B at the front okay sign
on the other hand is not even it's odd
okay so it works like this except in
Reverse
you've got your negative at the front so
therefore this is negative here I'm
gonna take out and put in the middle
okay so I'm gonna have - cause a side me
you see that so all I've done if you
like changing this plus write that plus
makes a plus over there so this minus
makes a minus over there okay so same
identity just slight adjustments okay we
can do the same kind of thing with cause
so let's see if we can remember we said
that the sign was mixed up you gotta
shines and closes together but close
keeps your functions the same right
so because it's a cos expansion which
start with cos cos a cos B and cos was
reversed after you you finished your
geometric exercise you notice you had a
negative here - then you've got your
science okay so you remember that now
therefore if we do the same thing here
if I have a minus B which is plus
negative B okay what would that mean
the eggs are the same and the bees
change okay
so therefore this cos of negative be
able to speak on me and this sign of
negative B will be negative so B so it's
gonna cancel that negative sign right so
cos of a minus B is equal to cos a cos B
because we remember those even right
plus sine a sine B okay so again same
idea of swapping but this time it's it's
upside down because the clause it's plus
turns into a minus
right and therefore it's - turns in
student pain plus so as a result
sometimes you'll see is all condensed
and get another car - because they're so
similar it's forming these expansions
right
sometimes you will see it written in
this way sine of a plus or minus B okay
because they're trying to collapse
things together the first term of war is
B sine a cause bed right and then when
you have in the middle depends on what
you had the stuff in the middle here
Simon okay exactly the same way you'll
get your cars off a plus or minus B but
because it's reversed here you'll get
the plus or minus sign but it will be
upside down that makes sense because
this class goes our this - as opposed to
this plus going with this bus okay so
they're not they're not you know
confused or have vertigo or anything
they just they're actually trying to
pair those up in tension okay all right
now there's the sign of the closed ones
okay now if you did your geometric
exercise for the reverse side of that
you have the tan ones already but
actually you can work out the tan ones
from here because tan is just a
relationship between some parts right so
for instance I've got some space I'll
keep going on you tan a plus B if I
wanted to work that out well ten is sign
over closed right so it'll be sine of
the same angle all uncaused off the same
angle okay now what do you think ooh I
know what these are both equal to right
there up here okay the first thing you
do is you just stop it in okay so this
is what it would look like but as you
start to write it out you think oh no
this is um this is not getting better it
is getting worse cuz I don't know why
here I would say that looks simpler than
this right however we can keep on going
a little bit here
with these four times okay I can divide
through all of them but one thing
that'll make it a lot simpler okay the
question is what's the one thing now if
you are if you have done the previous if
you've done the reverse side you can
sort of guess what I might divide by it
to make it all nice and me I'll take the
guesswork out for you because it'd be
faster you have a look at these four
terms okay I want to divide through
here's it here's a way that I might make
this in life that'll turn all these
signs and causes into different kinds of
tans okay different kinds of turns so
what would you choose after a little bit
of playing around because you can pair
them up in all these different ways okay
I'm gonna divide every term by sine a
sine B okay this four terms there if I
divide everything then I haven't really
changed anything yeah so I'm on the top
I'm gonna have sine a cos B on the sine
a sine B okay you can see this gonna be
some cancelling how can you get it right
in the same way I'll take this time and
divide it through sine X TV oh yeah yeah
that's exactly right
actually I've got it in reverse
let's try it again by the way since you
got your fractions on faculty right
might help you just to make it a little
clearer so you don't get confused where
your fraction starts where it ends this
term here
you can see it's going to cancel
completely right and this one on the end
you're gonna end up with a product how
does it work out okay you got your
cosby's over here to cancel
you've got your cause aids over here
that cancel this whole thing cancels and
ends up being just one right now what
you're left for you that's tan a son
cause this is tan be side of course and
this is 10 a and 10 because both of them
stick around right so I've got 10 a
front 10 B in the back and then one
minus
now in exactly the same way that you
haven't go to yourself as we did here
with the odd maven function business
right 10 is an odd function tangent
function okay and you can you can
remember that should I looking at it
like this
clear lit on even right but it's got a
same kind of symmetry this side
so therefore when I take when I switch
out which colored orange when I switch
out the A's for sorry the bees for
negative means right what effect will
that have on this what's going to switch
which signs will switch okay so I'll let
you have a go at that in a second and
then I'll write it up for you
that's the spirit okay so how did you
get there so I can say that n is an odd
function okay so if you wanna be shake
your save some some working even though
it's a wrong color it's a bit dangerous
to do this with your trig functions
because usually you know if violence
through here I couldn't simply put the
draw the front because it's an odd
function that negative sign can just go
out the front okay and the same thing
here that negative cancels with this
make a positive okay therefore just like
I did with sign it cuz if I want to put
both of these expansions the sum and the
difference together I could write it
like this ten a plus or minus big order
look like well you're gonna have fossil
- sorry on the top because can you see
this sign matches this sign right so
plus or minus matches I'll be plus or
minus on the bottom I'm gonna have the
thing I have it cuz right because this
negative if X is positive and if this
was positive like we had before you to
make this negative so I'm gonna have
both is a not plus or minus two minus or
plus
okay now just before we leave off
results and have a look at some of the
kinds of questions that you can look at
with this will generate what we call the
double angle results okay so double
angle means instead of having a and B
which are two different angles okay what
if I have well let's call it C a so a
plus a okay so it's the same expansion
as before but instead of sine a cos B
there's no big right the B is another a
okay so you'll get sine a cause a right
because I would have had be there and
then you can plus another sign a cause a
right so one plus one is two so there's
the double R is being the result for
sine okay what happens with cars hmm
okay usually we have cos a cos B cos a
cos B but there's no B it's another age
so your requires a cause a and you've
got cause find myself we say cos square
right and then you would have minus sine
a sine B but there's no pain it's still
the same as before it's another a right
so it's gonna be sign a sign a okay now
cos squared a minus signs for those so
this is very similar to the Pythagorean
I think cost with plus sine squared
equals one so don't get your confused
occasionally because you can use that
path Agora I didn't eat and switch out
say a closed square I can write that as
1 minus sine squared okay have you seen
that before right so therefore just
gathering my like terms I could say that
with the same logic I could get rid of
the sine squared and I could make this
one minus cos squared or on this side
okay so therefore instead of one minus
two sides where I've got cos squared
minus one minus cos squared okay so the
double negative
we'll combine and you get this okay so
all three of these I find they're all
legitimate okay they're just different
ways of saying this depending what kind
of information you've got or if you got
a trig identity depending on which one
of these everything looks more like
alright okay so I pause one more double
angle result it's on the board so you
guys could told me this one right what's
on the top to 10 ay coz 10a plus 10a and
on the bottom it'll be 1 minus and
instead of tan a 10 B it about the same
right so tan Hey
okay does he know any questions about
any of those results by the